all right welcome everybody to the third
of our free webinars this one we are
focusing on somebody new the last two we
did
Aristotle this time we're going to be
talking about Epictetus and we're
looking at probably one of the biggest
introductory doctrines for stoicism I
think that that's out there in present
modern day stoicism in fact some people
go so far as to portray it as being the
whole of stoicism so we're going to talk
quite a bit about this here's how I've
got the webinar set up I'm going to do a
few introductions we'll talk about the
Stoics in very very broad terms
Epictetus a little bit those of you who
who don't know me I'll do a quick
introduction to myself as the presenter
and then I've got five main topics that
I thought would be good for discussion
today in this free 45-minute webinar so
we'll talk about the dichotomy itself
and what is on both sides of it and then
we'll talk about what the consequences
are for getting it wrong and getting it
right and how we do that we're going to
look at some common objections and
challenges which should rise to
everybody's mind I think when first
reading through this and we'll look at a
particularly interesting proposed way of
addressing those challenges that William
Irvine put out in his book several years
back and then we'll talk about how
epictetus himself addresses those
challenges in looking at this concept of
use and we'll examine a few examples I
reserved 20 minutes for Question and
Answer and discussion so we should have
plenty of time for that
I'll ask everybody to hold their
questions until the end when it does
come time for a question answer I'll
remind everybody about this later on
that you can either use your mic or text
but I'd ask everybody to keep their mics
muted for the time being because we
don't want to get feedback and
we are trying to record it so let me
move on then into talking about stoicism
itself so stoicism is one of several
main schools in ancient philosophy and
it's not as old as some of them although
it's only a few generations younger it
gets started by this guy Zeno who is not
originally from Greece and he winds up
the story goes shipwrecked read
Xenophon's memorabilia which is about
Socrates asks where he can meet somebody
like that is pointed out one of the
cynics of the time craft ace and follows
him and learns from him for quite a
while but he also learns from others and
he in effect produces a new synthesis
and what if what ends up happening is
there are a few people who spin off with
their own doctrines from him but they
don't really laugh there's a there's a
clear progression from Zeno to Klee
Anthes and then precipitous is often
called the second founder of the school
what we're interested in with respect to
to stoicism here today is how we'd apply
it in in contemporary life and the
different of the third point here so
there have been revivals of interest in
stoic philosophy I caught on again and
the Renaissance and the early modern
period so you'll see modern philosophers
talking about the Stoics quite a bit
sometimes positively sometimes
negatively I'm going to kind of went
back into decline but in the last twenty
to thirty years it's taken on a whole
new impetus and interpretations in large
part because of the Internet this could
be something interesting to talk about
in the Q&A so let's talk about epictetus
now you notice that I'm calling him a
late stoic so he's somebody who is part
of the development of stoicism in its
last stages there is the early stoah the
people that we know we were talking
about before with Zeno and cruciferous
then
the middle stoah these would be people
like posted Onias and pen at TS we get
to know them in part through Cicero and
then there's the late stone and the late
store the people whose books we actually
have unfortunately lost most of stoic
literature so he you can see when he's
living he's he's in you know roughly the
the early part of the Roman Empire he's
born into slavery he winds up studying
stoicism with Sonia Sri ffice some of
whose works we still have he winds up
becoming freed and eventually becomes a
teacher of stoic philosophy um
he's forced to leave Rome because at a
certain point they kick all the
philosophers out and he settles in
accomplice and starts teaching there now
the works that we have by him are not
actually by him they are you might say
transcripts of the things that he taught
and said in classes the discourses is
much longer but we don't actually have
all of the books and then the
enchiridion is sort of the best hits
list all of these are set down by his is
a disciple and friend area I'm Greg
Sadler those of you who I think quite a
few of you looking at the guest list
here know me already I'm president of a
company that puts philosophy and
practice and provides these sorts of
workshops and and webinars I'm also the
editor of Stoicism today so I'm somebody
who has a role in the modern stoic
movement oftentimes just behind the
scenes I design and teach courses on
Epictetus and stoicism and I apply stoic
philosophy to work with individual
clients and organizations and
institutions so what I find is that you
know that's quite helpful learning about
where people encountering stoicism run
into the snags is something that I pay a
lot of close attention to and this
doctrine that we're going to look at
today seems to be one of those so let's
let's talk about the dichotomy itself
this is called in
temporary stuff the dichotomy of control
and it's not what a patinas himself
called it it was something that you
might say he he didn't call by any name
because he took for granted that it was
so basic for his students and he makes
this distinction in this court in
enchiridion chapter one and then in
discourses book one chapter one but
there's a lot of other places where it
keeps coming up and the best way to
translate it perhaps is what is in our
control and what is not in our control
as you can see the Greek words here are
at home own and oak epple mon f means
upon or towards and then the home own is
just the pronoun for first person plural
us right and so there are some things
that are up to us we could say or are
not up to us he's not the only person to
use this this distinction by the way
Aristotle had used it earlier the NIC
and McCain ethics but hadn't done quite
so much with it and we might think about
other ways that we could translate this
so in our control in our power those are
pretty synonymous another way of
translating it that I kind of like is
what's our business and what's not our
business when we say to somebody I you
know think that this is particularly
your business this is something that you
should be focused on we we mean that or
we sometimes say that's none of your
business and we often say this to try to
put people off but Epictetus might be
saying this in part to indicate what we
shouldn't be concerned with so making
the distinction you notice that we've
got two sides there and we could think
of them as two opposed sides
but what I was considering this I
thought well we really have not so much
two things on one side and on another
like two hands but rather we have the
inside and the outside the inside of a
person and the outside of a person so
that's another way of parsing out this
this distinction when we look at what he
actually says you'll see that it
conforms to this right what is in our
control you notice I've got a few Greek
terms and I'll explain those a little
bit so what we translate is conception
or sometimes assumption coupe ellipsis
that's coming from the word LOM bonding
meaning to grab and hoop ellipses have
become a technical term for something
like what we assumed to be the case
choice or another way of translating
this is is impulse [ __ ] may this is
another word that that we see the Stoics
bringing at the Wat and then desire and
aversion those are all things that
epictetus says are in our control as
examples and then he has this sweeping
term whatever is our own doing
HOSA Metra Aragon whatever is our own
function whatever is our own deed so
that sort of supports that you know our
business in other places he talks about
the ruling faculty tow hegemony cone
which includes the rational faculty and
the Faculty of choice these are all
really connected with each other that's
another topic we can go into that's
something within our control as well he
talks about this in discourses book one
chapter one and he talks about this as
being a faculty that has the capacity
for choice and refusal desire and
aversion and the use of external
impressions we're going to come back to
that word use in in a bit so if that's
what's in our control what's not in our
control well the body is an example of
something not in our control what else
proper
tasteless and Greek this will extend to
a lot of things reputation dachshund and
Greek positions or offices the Greek
word for that is arc I literally being
in a rulership position so you might
think of not just political office but
if you get a promotion at work or not
and then there's another catch-all
whatever is not our own affair and we
might think about this more broadly as
what is determined by other people or by
fate or the processes of the universe
and Epictetus stresses to us that were
in a position of having to choose one
thing or another
we can focus on what's really in our
control or we can focus on what is not
in our control or we can try this kicks
otic thing of trying to focus on both of
them and he says if you do that it's not
going to work we can't do two things at
once and this is not just doing two
things at once in a moment but doing two
things at once in the course of our life
he says you need to pick one side or or
the other so moving on what are the
consequences for getting this right and
getting it wrong there are different
consequences depending on where we put
our focus and he will spell that out for
us we're also going to have to be
concerned with another thing which is
whether we're getting the distinction
right in the first place he actually was
a bit of sort of side note trivia but
Epictetus talks about another thing that
people get quite confused about which
our general conceptions or
preconceptions these are sort of broad
ideas that we have that he says
everybody possesses they don't
contradict each other
in themselves but they do when we go to
apply them because they're kind of
confused in our heads
this distinction of what is in our
control and what is not in our control
these are he says preconceptions so
we can't take it for granted that we
automatically get it right every single
case what epictetus says is that if you
focus on the things that are not in your
in your control or in your power you're
going to be in a use of this term
hindered things are going to interfere
with you you're also going to experience
negative emotions and you'll blame the
gods and human beings on the other hand
if you focus on things that are in your
power he says nobody will ever be able
to compel or hinder you you'll blame and
find fault with no one you'll have no
enemies and nobody will harm you and all
of that sounds pretty wonderful doesn't
it so what is getting it wrong mean well
it means having a mistaken understanding
of what is in and what is not in our
control we often think that some things
are in our control when they're really
not we can we can know this on a you
might say cognitive level but not on a
practical level and epictetus thinks
that because of this when we have
desires and aversions those are going to
go out to things that we think are in
our control
so for mistaken about this we're going
to be having all sorts of desires and
aversions about things totally outside
of our control we'll also then start
making choices and longer term
commitments prioritizations you might
say weighing one thing against another
sacrificing one thing for another
and these are going to have bad outcomes
for us so those are consequences of
getting this distinction drawn another
important aspect to this are the
emotions right when when people feel
these emotions that that the Stoics view
as negative emotions or is problematic
it's often because they're focused on
things that are outside of their control
so fear or anxiety right when we're
preoccupied with what could happen to us
and either trying to do something about
it
you know or just feeling anxiety because
we can't do anything about it we have
the wrong attitude towards things that
are in our control or that are not in
our control rather sadness or grief sits
in with that envy or jealousy when we're
envious of other people were being
envious of things that are really none
of our own business
jealousy is wanting to hold on to
something that somebody else might might
try to take away from us but if it can
be taken away it's not really in our
control anger is a particularly
interesting one because anger not only
occurs in relation to things that are
outside of their control but anger also
tends to make us believe for the moment
that we actually can control things like
we can make the other person see the way
that we want you know them to see things
or impose the retribution that we demand
or we we can actually get back what we
lost irrational pleasure the stomach's
think that you should in fact feel some
measure of rational pleasure or joy but
when we feel far too much there's a
tendency for the things that we found
Pleasant we want to have more and more
and more and more of them and and very
often those are things outside of our
control shame or embarrassment
Epictetus thinks that a lot of the time
that were embarrassed about things were
embarrassed about things that we really
shouldn't find embarrassing great
example is poverty
Epictetus himself who you know lived as
a slave and was was poor at plenty of
times in his life and who lived simply
during his life said you know it's not
the poverty itself that's really
shameful it's the things that that you
might do in order to try to get out of
it those are the discourses or your
worries about other people and how they
perceive you
so the emotions fit in there and then
there's this hindrance idea when we're
hindered this is a term that's coming
from like being hobbled you know having
your feet chained together or something
like that something else interferes with
us
and our desires and our versions and our
plans now we can easily be hindered in
anything that's external to us for
example if we have to do a group project
and we want it to go a certain way this
is one reason why students hate to do
group projects other people can
interfere with that they can let us down
they can screw the project up they might
deliberately interfere with it you know
there's a personality conflict or they
can just get in the way there you're
having a committee meeting about it and
you just can't get this other person to
shut up they might not do what we want
and then there's a whole realm of
external objects that do what they do
and thereby interfere with us they they
don't work the way that we would like
them to work and we feel as if they are
against us some people so far as to
think that the weather is against them
or gravity it should be working
differently than that it does Epictetus
gives us some advice about getting it
right and so here's two bits that are
coming from the enchiridion he says it
with every harsh appearance we should
examine what the appearance you know is
and determine whether it's about
something in or outside of our control
so notice that some appearances could be
about things inside our control if we
you know look at ourselves in the the
proverbial mirror you know not not just
looking at a reflection but the thinking
about ourselves our like I don't like
this tendency that I have towards
overeating or losing my temper or not
following through on things that's in
our control so that that would be a
harsh appearance that we might not say
this to if it's outside then we ought to
be ready to say it's nothing to me
that's as is bit of advice that's
tougher to do than it sounds but we'll
talk about that in enchiridion - he's
got this really interesting discussion
of desire and aversion and he says that
we should withdraw aversion from what is
not in our control and this should be
actually transfer aversion to what is in
our control but what is bad so if I
don't like the fact that I'm Carol
this in how I spend money you know
because I have desires for things or
versions that are getting me into
trouble and I don't like to think about
that maybe I need to transfer my
aversion to that so that I dislike that
aspect of the way I'm living and then
start to try to change that he says that
we should also try to remove desire
entirely from things that are outside
our control and like I put here that's
extremely tough to do so we have to
think about that in gradual steps rather
than all at once now this raises here's
the third topic a lot of objections
students will often say things like wait
a second you're saying my body isn't in
my control but but I choose whether I
you know wash it or feed it properly or
exercise or you know sleep you know
instead of watching a shows all night
long and epictetus actually grants
something like this in this course is
for point one this is another thing
where he's talking but he says films can
be uh not under our control
in a couple different ways whether we
have them or don't have them or whether
we have them with a certain quality
and/or you know whether they have you
know like I can have a coffee I choose
that I don't choose necessarily whether
the coffee is hot or good or anything
like that or to have in a certain way in
in relation you might say to other
things so those are important
clarifications and we might make some
objections right don't we have control
over our body it seems like you do to
some extent what about finances I choose
whether I save or spend personal
relationships
I choose whether in personal
relationships or not my career whatever
that happens to be it seems like I have
some measure of control over that like
if I if I know that I need a particular
degree or certificate it's up to me to
go get it and if I don't get it then
that's up to me reputations or legacy
mobiles all seem to be real objections
and we might also go the other way what
about things that are in our control do
we really want to say all of our desires
and aversions are totally in our control
or our emotions our emotional responses
are totally in our control our opinions
and judgments can we can we decide that
something that we think is the case
really isn't the case or not
maybe Epictetus is wrong about this this
sort of stuff so the question we want to
ask is whether epictetus has responses
to this if he doesn't then we've got a
real problem with this distinction so
epictetus set doesn't say that we
shouldn't care at all about external
things and we're going to talk in just a
little bit about the use of those things
he does say that we're given those
things for some time so you know our
bodies are our bodies they're not going
to last forever and we don't control
every aspect of them but they are our
bodies my body is my body not your body
and vice versa
and notice to that being in control does
not always mean that we have immediate
control over those things so there are
some things where habit plays a very
important role if I know that I have a
tendency to eat more than I should
because and I you know look at it I say
well I'm having these snacks as I watch
a show at night to unwind maybe that's
where I need to cut back I start
modifying my habits and at first it's
very difficult to modify happens right
so we have to engage in what Epictetus
calls ascesis this is a Greek word that
means training or or discipline and so
some things are under our control but
not under our control in the sense that
we can change them by turning on the you
know proverbial dime we have to steer a
ship he's like this metaphor steer a
ship that that actually takes a while to
turn so now another way of trying to
deal with this is proposed by Bill
he has a book called the guide to the
good life and he says that the phrase
some things aren't up to us is ambiguous
it can be understood to mean either
there are some things over which we have
no control or there are things over
which we don't have complete control and
so this leads him to propose a
trichotomy as opposed to a dichotomy so
notice that he's adding in a third
category things over which we have some
but not complete control and the key
question to ask for this is can we get
the same effect from epictetus dichotomy
should we go Ervin's path or should we
stick with Epictetus himself the real
issue is that middle category right what
is partly in our control we control one
aspect of this but not the other so the
way irvine talks about this is we
control the intention but not the
results and he calls the process of
dealing with this internalizing the
goals so for example he likes to talk
about tennis
he must imagine play quite a bit and
he'll talk about playing to your best
ability you have control over that
whether you play to your best ability
but you don't control whether you win
the game or not because you could still
be a terrible player and your good could
be just you know quite awful or you
could be playing against a pro or the
wind could be against you or you know
you could add up all sorts of other
things now I think that epictetus
already has resources for addressing
this sort of thing and for making the
kind of distinction that irvine is is
proposing so if we look at his
discourses he tells us that a number of
points that externals as such are not
within our power but the use of those
things outside of our control
in something that we do have control
over and this word use is in Greek
crisis and use is a really good way of
translating it but another way we can
translate is dealing with it's what we
do with with things and epictetus says
that our use off to be prudent it ought
to be proper we have sir
guidelines for this so here's some
examples right with our body we should
in fact make proper use of and care for
for our body he's got a chapter on
cleanliness in the discourses where he
says well you actually should you know
clean your body because it's like any
other possession you want to keep it in
good repair and we might say the same
thing about wealth or property or
reputation position and offices how we
use these things impacts what's really
at our core which is this Faculty of
choice or prior ASIS
it has important implications for that
now here's a one example that he has but
I think drives this home this is in
discourse as two point five he says you
can make a voyage you decide you're
going to Egypt for example and taking
voyages in ancient times is kind of
perilous so you do have control over
some things you control what ship you
get on you control the captain and the
crew that you're willing to hire for
this you know if they're drunk all the
time maybe don't take that ship and you
can control the time to sail and the
Epictetus says you should in fact uh pay
attention to these things once your ship
is sailing though the storm can come up
and you can be shipwrecked it could turn
out that the sailors lied to you and
they don't actually know how to sail
there's all sorts of things you know
provided you've done your due diligence
you can actually say well I I did what I
ought to have done another great example
is playing ball this is also in
discourses two-point-five he says we
should imitate the skilled ball player
he doesn't worry about whether the ball
is good or bad he will he focuses on
catching and throwing the ball
skillfully and actually if you start
thinking too much playing balls a great
example you start thinking too much
about how you're playing ball that often
interferes doesn't it with playing
skillfully now here's where it becomes a
really interesting metaphor Socrates was
playing ball in the walk court during
his trial how did he do that well if you
if you read the apology weather
Xenophon's or Plato's
you'll see him cross-examining the the
people who accused him and showing that
they their charges don't really have any
merit but not in such a way that he
would win the case as a matter of fact
he managed to alienate the the jury
pretty pretty clearly if you've read it
you might say what was he doing there
right well he was focusing on something
else he was focusing on remaining true
to his principles not on whether he won
or lost this is time that we've got set
aside for questions and answer I ran a
little bit over time Andy is going to I
think field some of the questions that
will come up in the chat window so if
you want to ask questions with that
that's that's great otherwise you can
unmute your mic and I should be able to
hear you with that
I think we have a few questions in the
chat there's nothing in the chat yet
Craig I just posted that people could
post a question there if they needed
something read aloud it could be the
people of typing though that's the one
thing we don't know if someone is typing
a question right now or not what we then
in the meantime I always have much more
material than and I bring out in these
because there's quite you know a lot of
material associated with this we talk
about another really interesting example
that Epictetus has which i'll be talking
about in a interview later on next week
so he's got an example of a kid or a
player and a caterer has a musical
instrument this is somebody who's
playing and singing at the same time and
he says this person is really good at
this he's practice he you know he's got
that muscle memory he knows exactly
where his fingers go and so he feels
confidence he doesn't feel anxiety about
his performance when he's practicing
he's just fine when he's in an empty
room he's just fine put him in front of
a crowd and now suddenly he gets worried
about that and epicly says what's going
on there he clearly knows what he's
doing he's got talent he's got a skill
so why is he worried and he says he
becomes worried because he starts to be
preoccupied to something that's outside
of his control he knows that he can play
well he doesn't know how the whole
audience is going to respond and because
he allows himself to get concerned with
what the audience response is going to
be his entire emotional comportment
changes it goes from being confident to
being anxious it goes from knowing that
he can he's up to any challenge that
he's going to run into to worrying about
what the crowd is going to think and you
know there's all sorts of cases in our
own lives where it's precisely like that
you know
think about when you put together a
presentation for at work and you've got
to present a proposal and you know your
proposal is really good but going in
front of that audience you don't control
what their responses are going to be and
if you you know become preoccupied with
that is where your good and your bad lie
then you're going to feel some some
worry or something else maybe you
project some anger towards them who are
they to to judge me or or you get sad or
other things arise hey Greg we've got a
couple of questions in the chat window
Derek says weird to read more on a
thesis training according to the Stoics
oh well so I mentioned the MU sonjia's
Rufus who is epictetus teacher we still
possess some writings by him we have
these lectures in these fragments he
talks about it quite a bit and he
actually gives some some interesting
guidelines particularly pertaining to
like a food and drink and and how we
ought to behave
Epictetus talks about it at a number of
points in the discourses you'll see it
mentioned in the in karidian but you're
not getting a lot of discussion about it
but yeah I'm a discourses I mean there's
there's some discussion of it also in
Marcus Aurelius Seneca has a lot of
useful things to say about it as well
not sure actually what the Wratten term
it might be dis completa or something
like that and I'm trying to recall
whether there's any in-depth discussions
in Cicero who is not a stoic himself but
who gives us a lot of information about
the Stoics but I'm drawing a bit of a
blank on that but if you if you dig
around in the discourses if you only
pick one source I would say go to epic -
this is discourses and just start
reading around and you will find him
talking quite a bit about what what
ascesis would would comprise we have two
more chests johanna just
thanks for the Greek words and their
meanings I know that that's very helpful
and Lawrence asks are concepts related
to stoicism oh okay well let me actually
first say Johanna you're very welcome I
always have to watch that I don't lapse
into too much Greek words because of if
a tendency but but it is useful to have
them in front of us now can't okay so
Kant is an interesting guy
Conte is known as being you know one of
the big day ontological thinkers and
danfa logical thinkers stress many of
the same themes that stoicism does like
fulfilling your duties right and that
the intention is really what what
matters that we don't have control over
the the ultimate effects or outcomes in
many cases the whole notion of freedom
and freeing ourselves from irrational
desires and living a rational life all
of that can some very stoic er can sound
very conscious I would say that the key
difference is in how can't understands
what all of this would mean so for the
Stoics for example we have certain
impulses within us as as creatures by
being the kind of creatures that we have
so one one great example is what we call
familial affection in Greek Phyllis
Toria
the Stoics thought that parents
naturally feel affection towards their
children and that's a good thing and we
want to do that and epictetus actually
has a great chapter and I think it's an
if I remember right it's in book one I'm
going to say it's like 12 or 13 about
Phyllis target where he's clarifying
with with a guy who's claiming that his
bad behavior is motivated by that epic
uses note that that's something quite
different Kant would say that that's
morally valueless Kant thinks that the
only thing that gives something moral
value is that it is it is chosen as
a rational action for for its own sake
it's a little bit more technical than
that when we get to it but so you can
say that with [ __ ] interesting
similarities but that he's doing a whole
different kind of thing I think that's
it for questions for now from the chat
box but I'll certainly let you know if
anything else pops up in the next Q&A
okay well you know one other thing that
I'll mention too is and since we brought
up a modern philosopher Kant and I did
mention that stoicism and had kind of a
revival in the Renaissance and then in
the early modern period I think a lot of
early modern thinkers were very
attracted to this distinction between
what is in our control and what's not in
our control you see it playing a role
for example in Rene de cartes ethics he
he doesn't do it quite the same way as
the Stoics do but he does in the
meditations and a few other works where
he's laying out some some ethics he is
using that same distinction of saying it
we get in trouble when we focus on
things outside of our control we need to
stick to the things that are we do have
one more question Greg is sort of
connected to what you're just talking
about if you wanted me to remit now or a
table okay so Laurence asks it shows
them something that is still evolving as
society moves on in any ways or is it
mostly set in stone oh that's a big
question and it's actually something
I've been thinking about quite a bit
both in general and in relation to this
particular issue of what's in our
control and what's not in our control so
let me answer let me put that stuff on
the side for the moment and just try to
give a very general answer there are
people in the present who call
themselves traditional Stoics or or
knock Stoics and they view stoicism as
essentially cast in stone
they sometimes disagree a bit about how
much you have to buy into and they treat
it it almost in a quasi-religious way as
a matter of fact one group actually has
a ordination process for becoming an
ordained stoic philosopher so that would
be at one extreme then there are people
who are what we might call if I'm going
to pick in a little title for them
stoicism light or sure Marcus Borg
stoicism right and it's very much a
matter of I just use the little bits
that help me and say forget all the rest
and oftentimes they're their basic
direction their basic orientation may be
at odds with some of the other things
that the Stoics say in the middle and
the middle is always messier than in
extremes right are people who are having
this conversation about like well what
what parts of stoicism might we need to
adapt differently what parts might we
need to get rid of altogether what parts
do we need to not only keep but insist
upon that's that's where I think a lot
of the the people like say Donald
Robertson or Massimo Piggly achior Bill
Irvine find themselves is in that messy
middle and that's the most interesting
place I think so now they have said we
we do live in a culture that is changing
very quickly and when it comes to what's
in our power and what's in it not in our
power I think that this distinction is
going to have a lot of really
interesting applications so let me give
you two examples that I've been thinking
about what's not in our power our body
right and we might say wait a second you
know I have so many things I can do to
my body that show how much I do control
it you know we know so much more about
exercise and its principles
we have all these great technologies
that we use in medical things and you
can say sure you can you can do all that
you can still drop dead tomorrow
and and we're now at the point where
because of our control our semi control
over things think about antibiotics we
have exercised so much pseudo control
over you know parts of the living world
that we now have bred superbugs and you
can get these sometimes by going into
the hospital so people go to the
hospital the place where you're supposed
to go to get cured and come out with and
you know antibiotic resistant staph
infections and sometimes die of it so
you know we find ways in which even
though we live in this incredibly
advanced technological society it keeps
giving keeps getting driven home to us
that things are ultimately not in our
control if they're really externals
another example of this would be our
[Music]
technology that we have you know like
think about our iPhones and all this you
know video conferencing and think about
where it's going to be 20 years from now
where we probably will have quite a few
implants and we're going to be enhancing
our abilities in so many different ways
now to what degree do we remain in
control and at what point does the
technology begin to control things much
more I think a stoical perspective is
very handy for think doing this
futuristic kind of thinking because it
starts out with a assumption about
minimal control that's counterintuitive
to what many of the people making
predictions about this tend to hold
which is that well if we can push a
button we control it there's so many
things that can go go wrong and go go
overboard I think if epictetus were
around today he would be talking with
the futurists and probably deflating
some of the optimistic bubbles that they
they're doing and I think that's a good
thing
so that's that's that's what I'll say
about that I see that there's some more
questions
yeah so Randall says it strikes me that
the Buddhist idea of impermanence and
accepting it fits with the notion of not
focusing and things out of our control
yeah I would say that there's a
similarity there and there's also a big
dissimilarity in that you know for the
Buddhists ultimately there there isn't a
a self in the traditional sense where we
can talk about it as being you like the
core of the person whereas for the stoic
there definitely is it's that you know
ruling principle or our principle our
Faculty of choice however we want to
parse these out so there the other thing
is Gregg Lopez has a really nice piece
on this recently in stoicism today
comparing Buddhist and stoic notions of
attentiveness or mindfulness and so
they're their similarities and then
there's some really big distal
similarities as well but they're
laughing I'll say about it there's a
quite a community of people who are
drawing these connections and sort of
working them out in practice so we're
fortunate that we have a number of
people I'm not one of them I don't know
enough about the stuff to say anything
really effective but there are a number
of people who are doing some pretty cool
research into this ok we have one more
comment here with a question and Derek
says I've been interested in stoicism
for about a year and I still find the
idea that I don't have control over
things like success to be awed did the
ancient Stoics assume that people just
naturally worked at being successful the
seems like they must have acknowledged
that something takes some work planning
goals etc yeah and like I said epictetus
does think that let me put it to you
this way
they're definite ways that you can make
sure to not be successful right if you
walk around the marketplace with your
pants on your head and and you know
throwing a lot of melons at people
nobody's going to hire
there's some weird Job Description for
that sort of thing right and nobody's
going to put you in political office
they may elect you to you know village
idiot or something like that but I don't
know if that counts as success let's
hire that so there's there's certainly
things that we can do to make make
success not happen but there's a lot of
things that we we would have to do if
we're striving after something external
and so Epictetus talks for example about
somebody who's going to Rome and is
going to be in a walk ace and how
they'll probably need to do this and do
that including you know making a
particular argument to the jury and
bribing the judges or whatever and he
also talks about trying to get political
political appointments in Rome too and
how you're going to have to need to
grease the wheels either with affection
or money or something like that
so there is a clear recognition that
there are some things if what you're
really after is people calling you a
good guy or giving you in office or
thinking you know wonderful things and
and and we're you know spreading your
fame far and wide there are things you
can do but none of them are guaranteed
to actually be successful you're also
doing so in a environment where other
people are doing the same thing so
you're competing with them and even if
you do get those things you're probably
not going to be happy yeah so whatever
whatever measure of seeming control you
have over success is is it's not the
same setting sort of control is we have
over whether we really are good people
are on that or work upon ourselves or
anything along those lines I think that
the ancients weren't very different than
us in those respects they they had clear
ideas about what you needed to do to get
ahead the question is how you evaluate
it and remember to that Epictetus is
saying something countercultural in his
own time just as he is in our time in
saying that that's not where your
attention should be focused
okay great that's it for now and I'll
make note of any new chat comments that
come in as we move through the next
section oh no where we're at the end
that's alright
whether you guys you're thinking of the
two hour let me actually move up to that
then so useful
Epictetus resources on the same topic
we're going to have some to our online
seminars an epic teams from the Academy
of control or look at a lot of other
examples and we're going to go more into
depth on some of these issues those will
be May 10th I've got them set at 10 a.m.
and 4 p.m.
tried to make it so that people
worldwide could attend as easily as
possible but I do think that there's a
zone where it's still a lot of tricky
for people we also have online courses
and the reason I own Academy there's a
free Epictetus as enchiridion course
which which is a thinking al got about
six hundred people enrolled in it so it
actually qualifies as a MOOC and will
have an epic two discourses class coming
soon this is a on demand work at your
own pace course with lots of resources
and videos and then of course some of
you have probably already poked around
in there but I do have a stoicism
playlist in my main youtube channel
which now has around 95 videos and I'll
be adding some some further ones later
on this month so those could be quite
handy for for further follow up on this
so let me say thanks for all of these
great questions I really enjoy doing
this this sort of stuff and have a great
rest of the day everybody